hi there today we're looking at
reinforcement learning fast and slow
Matthew button bought linic Sam Ritter
Jane X Wang zap Kurt Nilsen Charles
bundle and Dennis hassabis these people
are from google deepmind and this is a
review of kind of development in
reinforcement learning especially as it
pertains to kind of how humans learn or
what we can understand from the RL world
that translates over to human learning
all right so basically their their
argument here is that the first wave of
deep RL as you see here is powerful but
slow and they give examples of this so
in box one box one is this so they
believe there's an image missing here
this is backgammon TD gammon this is the
famous deep mind Atari a playing bot and
this is kind of the 3d labyrinth playing
bots so that there's been a number of
advances in RL and especially what they
talk about is deep RL so when we talk
about reinforcement learning the easiest
case is where you have an agent agent
and an environment meant all right so
the agent will observe some observation
from the environment and then based on
that the agent will perform an action a
and then the environment will give back
a reward and also a next observation so
this is a 0 a 1 right and then this is a
zero and then here you give a 1 AI so
basically this goes back and forth and
back and forth the agent performs an
action the environment gives a reward
and the next observation so this could
be
for example here in the in the Atari
world the observation is the screen
itself right and then the agent needs to
perform an action which is an input of
the joystick or pressing some button you
can see the individual actions actually
listed here and then the reward will be
given to the agent via a number which I
guess is the same number as up here so
that task is to maximize the reward
simply by so the difference is you're
not doing this in a supervised manner so
you're not telling the agent what would
be the correct action to do you simply
tell it that whether what it did was
good or bad by giving it a high or a low
reward right so that's reinforcement
learning so what is deep reinforcement
learning deep reinforcement learning
simply means the agent Maps the
observation to the action via a deep
neural network so deep neural network
that that that's deep reinforcement
learning where the the mapping or some
part of the agent consists of a deep
neural network and that's you see for
example here there is a deep neural
network mapping the observation to the
action as well as down here but it's a
bit more complicated all right so they
argue that the first wave of this was
powerful but slow meaning kind of um you
need a lot of samples and they give two
sources of why it's slow why you need a
lot of samples they say the two factors
are incremental parameter adjustment and
weak inductive bias so incremental
parameter adjustment means basically
that you have to update or Terrain your
neural network in a very small
incremental way in order to basically
because you train it one by one right
you train your neural network
step by step you have to make small
steps in order to not forget what what
came before
you can't fundamentally readjust your
neural network to every new batch of
observations because then that's gonna
destroy all the information you've
learned of the old one and then weak
inductive bias here is is a basically an
understanding of these neural networks
they are general function approximate
errs and they can approximate any
function so if you just think in terms
of kind of I don't know let's say
polynomials and what kind of polynomial
this polynomial this polynomial this
polynomial this weird polynomial if I
have a function that can approximate all
of these then I have a weak inductive
bias whereas if I kind of know okay all
my polynomials are the polynomial that
I'm looking for ultimately I'm very sure
it's a third-degree polynomial right so
something like this or like this or like
this so this is much less of a much less
of the class of functions that I can fit
but if I'm sure that the function that
I'm trying to fit falls in this category
then I'm much faster so this is then
called a strong inductive bias is where
I build into the model basically I tell
it beforehand
here is a very restricted class of
functions that you can fit whereas in a
weak inductive bias I won't tell it that
I'll simply say it well model you could
fit any function you want and I'm just
giving you training samples so this is a
yeah a classic example of a bias
variance trade-off where there is
there's a lot of variance in these
models meaning you can fit also a lot of
functions but here because you buy us
the model towards a certain set of
functions it can lower this variance and
in this case here they argue it speeds
up learning because you don't have your
own
as much variance that means you can
basically go faster while learning
alright so they proposed to two
solutions to this problem of this kind
of to mitigate these problems that make
reinforcement learning faster or have
made reinforcement learning faster but
this is a review room and remember so
the first one is episodic deep
reinforcement learning and this episodic
deep reinforcement learning is specified
here and fast learning through episodic
memory so what the suggestion in this
field of research is to augment the
neural network or the agent by a memory
and the memory could look something like
this
so in a lot of these RL frameworks what
you what a principal component of the
agent is so the agent will get an
observation oh and one of the things it
has to do is estimate the value of this
observation of this state so basically
the agent isn't some state let's say you
play pong right and you are here down
and the ball comes your way up there
right there's a little arrow sorry so
the ball flies away from you and you're
all the way down which basically means
draw this bigger so here you are down
here and the ball is here flying up
there so one task in these in these
agents that occurs often is to estimate
the value of this observation basically
means how much reward am I expecting
from this state going into the future in
this case I probably will not expect a
lot of reward since I can't move up fast
enough right to catch the the ball so
this I would assign this state a pretty
low value whereas if I were up here I
would assign this state
quite a high value so as we've already
seen this is a this is a deep neural
network mapping we learn to assign value
to different states and this is one of
the parts that takes a long time and
these methods they are the one that's
depicted here replaces this value
estimation by saying okay we have an
observation we somehow need to estimate
its value why why don't we look for
similar observation so we have some kind
of memory right and we go with our
observation and we retrieve Oh prime one
Oh prime two Oh prime three there are
somehow similar right so in our in our
pong example I'm down I'm up here ball
moves here I could be looking now at at
states where I was here or where I was
here like really close or where the ball
flew a bit differently but still in the
same direction or down here right so all
these states are kind of close to my
state and I can I already have I already
have played these since they're in my
memory right so with every one of them I
can also retrieve the rewards that I got
so all because I already know the
problem in reinforcement learning is
before you do an action you don't know
what the real world will be but here I
already know because I've played it I've
already experienced it it's in the past
so I know what reward I got all right so
and this is exactly what they say over
here they basically say here we have
time time runs this way we're in state
one then in state two and so on and we
perform actions and and get rewards and
what we can do is we can save these
states into this memory along with their
sum of discounted rewards that we
collect from that state on and then
later
this is like a spongebob reference if we
want to estimate the value of some new
state right what we do is we retrieve
all of these states from memory
calculate a similarity score over them
and with with we wait basically we add
their rewards weighted by how similar
they are to the state that we want to
compute so this basically amounts to
averaging over states respected by how
close they are to the current state this
is kind of a soft a soft way of saying I
only select the states which are close
and that gives you a value estimate for
the new states so basically this means
you just got rid of having to train a
value function and this will speed up
your reinforcement learning quite a bit
if you don't have to train that if you
already have good value estimations from
your previous experience that's great of
course there are a number of problems
associated with that namely if this
memory here for example becomes stale it
doesn't represent the future rewards
quite as well there is also a question
of which states do you keep in memory
just the good ones or do I have to have
a certain property do you have to have
some diversity in there and of course
the biggest problem here the biggest
problem is how do you know when two
states are similar or when they aren't
it might be easy in a situation like
pong where I only have like three
variables like position a Y position of
my my paddle and position of the ball
and velocity of the ball
those are like I can specify those in
five numbers but if it gets harder than
that if it's like this labyrinth setting
full 3d environment then we have no clue
which states are similar to each other
and what this what most end up doing is
they will train you guessed it they will
train a deep
that work to give you this similarity
score between states right how they do
it is is a different question but
presumably you can train this network
offline basically meaning you can pre
train it you could pre train it and then
the so we have two stages stage one pre
train train similarity DNN right there's
an M and then once we've done that
second stage do reinforcement learning
using this and the claim here is that by
having there's done this the second
stage will become faster so it it
doesn't really solve the problem of the
sample efficiency but what it says is
okay the actual reinforcement learning
part will become faster because we've
already done the work previously but
basically by by including this
similarity score sorry
whatever DNN by including this in the
language of the review here we have
successfully introduced an inductive
bias into the RL procedure because the
RL procedure now can't just fit any
function we say we tell it your value
function is one that conforms to our
notion of similarity that we've
pre-trained this restricts the RL
algorithm and we give it an inductive
bias and as long as our similarity score
is useful for the RL argh algorithm it
can speed up its learning because it
doesn't have to learn the value function
itself all right cool so the second part
here is a bit more abstract called meta
reinforcement learning speeding up deep
or out by learning to learn it's kind of
learning to learn approaches are quite
abundant in the literature people try
this usually there's a I mean it's it's
very large-scale experiments basically
you have I think I'll show it somewhere
yeah you have like some some outer loop
where you would say that's this thing
here what the outer loop does is in each
loop it samples one environment so it
samples one environment from a
distribution of environments so now you
not only have one environment but you
say okay if I'm going to navigate this
maze wanted trying to learn to navigate
this maze I'm going actually to learn to
learn to navigate many mazes right so
it's not like you train one agent to
learn you train one agent to navigate
many mazes that would just be classic
reinforcement learning but you wanna
train an algorithm that helps an agent
learn as a particular maze and you do
that by training your helper algorithm
on a variety of agent maze combinations
so in each step you sample one
environment like this this here and you
then have an inner loop here you fully
reinforcement learn train an agent in
the classic sense on this environment
right you see here action action
observation reward right but the agent
receives some kind of signal from
outside so the outside algorithm will
kind of tell the agent how to approach
the problem all right
this could be that it initializes the
the weights here you see that the outer
loop terrains the parameter weights
which determine the inner learner that
interacts with an environment during the
duration of the episode for every cycle
of the outer loop a new in ran
environment is sampled from a
distribution of environments which share
some common structure so basically the
one would expect when you train this
that these parameters here this could be
for example it could be the initial
weights of the network
that the agent uses that is one
possibility right this is very abstract
here this metal reinforcement learning
it could be literally anything that the
outer model teaches the inner model or
gives to the inner model right and you
you train both of these with
reinforcement learning so the inner you
train with reinforcement learning on the
individual rewards and then you can
train the outer loop on the reward that
the entire app agent environment episode
achieved so the that's kind of a two
loop situation and yeah so that's metal
reinforcement learning
again it's very unspecified what it does
but as you can already see if you now
have such an algorithm that kind of
tells the inner agent just as an example
how to initialize its weights right how
to initialize the weight of its deep
neural network if you have that here
then the agent you will technically bias
it this is again an inductive bias so
you will give it inductive bias towards
what you think are good weights to
generally learn these maize structured
environments right
since the outer loop you can update it
way slower because it needs to learn
over a longer time horizon and it needs
to learn things for a different variety
of environments but once you have good
kind of initial weights for a particular
environment then this agent in here can
learn much faster given an individual
environment so the agent you instantiate
it and then you give it good starting
weights or some other kind of signal
about the environment and then it can go
much much faster at learning the
environment thereby you have just sped
up this inner agent by providing it an
inductive bias and that's basically what
what the the these
what the claim of the review is that by
providing these models with a larger
inductive bias you may then speed up
their learning because you've kind of
told them what good functions are on the
out from the outset of course you see
the problem again here what the problem
the problem is of course you actually
need to train this outer sorry this this
outer loop and the outer loop may
actually take much much longer to train
than a single unn and the unbiased
reinforcement learning thing but again
what you could do is you could pre train
on a distribution of environments and
then once a new environment shows up
that it's similar to this distribution
you can then have the agent instantiated
and learn much faster so again kind of
this two-step process you could
pre-trained this outer loop and then the
inner loop will be much faster than if
you didn't have the outer loop alright
so those are basically the kind of the
kind of outlines they do here they then
kind of do a connection to like the
brain and so on and they relate this to
biology and biological learning but
ultimately their conclusion is here that
whenever you want to do whenever you
have slow RL or this is at least my
conclusion from their article whenever
you have slower L you can transform it
to fast RL RL but you have to outsource
the slow RL slow something else
slow X you have to outsource the
slowness to some other part so if you
want to do fast RL you have to outsource
the slowness and what the slowness
provides is an inductive bias
which means yeah if you want to do like
faster Ella with episodic memory you
have to learn the similarity function
which again which might be slow in
itself but then the RL will be fast and
if you want to do this via kind of a an
outer metal earner again this learning
of the outer petal order might be slow
but then the inner learner will be fast
in a connection to the kind of
biological aspect of this they do make a
connection which which I find is
appropriate in that for example the
human brain the reason we can learn
things fast let's say in the physical
world picking things up dropping things
down or navigating our paths we're
incredibly good at this navigating
through like a weird terrain with rocks
in the way is because of course our
brains have been adapted to these kinds
of environments over generations so
there is an outer process like evolution
which is this kind of outer loop and it
instantiates the inner loop which are
the humans that kind of live or die by
their ability to to navigate better so
the if if the outer loop does a good job
of only keeping the humans alive that
can navigate well then the individual
human in here that that does this the
individual human given a landscape with
rocks will then be much faster at
learning to navigate it alright so that
was it for that I it's an interesting
article to read especially the
connections to the kind of biological
aspects and with that have a nice day